well crystal method you are almost a
winner baby
top three so close what is making top
three mean to you i mean you've been
sitting on this secret for a minute
it's so exciting you know in the
beginning
um i was just really trying to
not go home i was so i was really
nervous in the beginning of the
competition i think it was pretty
obvious
um but once i started you know just
stepping into like what i do best and
having fun
because that's like the reason i do drag
is to just have fun
um that's when i started really
succeeding so it feels really really
good to have finally
made it to the top and i feel honored to
like
be in the top three with jada and gigi
because
oh those are my talented sisters i love
them
from the bottom i made it to the top
well let's
look into the future that crown is on
your head
what is your message to america after
being named america's next
drag superstar uh my message would be
um to embrace your weirdness and embrace
what makes you different because
that is what makes you special and
powerful
and drag has become something that's
like um
i don't know everyone's pretty similar
sometimes like
but i i would hope that my my potential
win would mean
um it would just encourage people to
step outside of
what they think drag even is um
and to really try and push the art form
forward i
i love drugs so much and so it would
just be such an honor
you said that the change for you in the
competition came when you let yourself
have
fun what was that moment for you can you
pinpoint it back to a certain challenge
i can i can't i wrote it in my diary
it was the rusical challenge i took
myself on a journey
a singing dancing challenge is not
something that you know
i thought i would like excel in
but i really was like i am going to give
100 and i'm gonna do it the best to my
ability
and and i even i just wrote i was like
i'm gonna be in the top and from here on
this is my
story out change i'm going to do good
every time
and somehow it happened i spoke it into
existence
maybe it was all the prayers you were
doing on stage oh yeah all the hippy
dippy vibes
that sent it into the universe yeah
uh well you know this is an
entertainment tonight interview so i
have to ask about your personal life
the fans think you and gigi are more
than just
sisters of course me and gigi are soul
mates
um it's so strange to like go on the
show and
you know i'm i'm friends with all the
girls but for some reason
her and i just can just were able to
connect
um really well we're fans of like what
each other do
and we like both teach each other
stuff it's so weird um i've been loving
all of the um fan videos
of us like all our little side parts
over just laughing
and dancing together um and they always
put it to romantic music
[Music]
we'll see we're in quarantine so we
haven't been able to spend that much
time together but
once we get back um in the same room
maybe we will see how a relationship
goes
okay i'm excited by that
all right do you know who el debarge is
now
do you know you have the hair of elder
barge
i don't know who that is no i definitely
know who elder barge is
now i'm very curious um if he knows who
i am
i was gonna say have you heard from
elder barge or his
children or anything i haven't heard
anything yet but i do know that if you
search elder barge on google i'm one of
the pictures that shows up
so hey you've made your mark
do you still have the mullet under there
oh yes it's getting long
it's still gorgeous i'm i really
am gonna get it down to my butt before i
even think about cutting it
okay next level yeah let's talk about
the season
was there a quote for you of the season
a moment that was like
this is drag race history it could be
something you said something somebody
else said that just sticks out to you
a quote from the show that sticks out to
me let me think
um
[Music]
look over there i think that is the big
one
yeah everything that comes out of jada's
mouth
is um just gold um
i love hearing her talk and go on and on
um she's one of the funniest people i've
ever met
look over there if for some reason you
have to come back
and compete on an all-star season what's
something you would want redemption for
i think if i can't if if i was forced to
come back for an all-stars
um i would just try and have more
fun the whole time i feel like um you
know you go into the competition you
don't know what to expect at all
especially like
it's a lot of our first time like being
on a big
hollywood set um so i would just try and
be more comfortable
more confident especially with all the
improv challenges
um i would just lean into all of that
more
and have more fun and try and be more
myself i feel like on the show
sometimes um i you know you're kind of
um in your head about how you're gonna
be perceived
um so now that i know that everyone
loves me
um i would just be myself more
hey i like it is there anything you feel
like you need to apologize for from this
season
maybe my buttons and bows runway
um not one of my favorite things i've
ever done that was one of the pieces
that
like was still being sewn together while
i was packing to leave
um and it went into my suitcase
unfinished
okay it wasn't that bad seeing it on
television
but i was going to say i don't remember
thinking it was bad
i remember having nightmares about it i
was like i don't ever want to see this
thing again
but you know hey you made it to top
three i sold the garment something right
yeah i sold the garbage yes ma'am
i know we're gonna get a finale probably
like we've never seen before what kind
of preparation went into this finale
making it work on the time crunch
because it
it's still a race um it's
that's one of the crazy things is like i
was in quarantine for the show and now
i'm just in quarantine again it feels
like i've been stuck
on this show forever well i am
interested to see how this finale goes i
hope to see a crown on your head and i
hope to see you and gigi you know
having cute couple moments on instagram
yeah creepy
creature forever